I that's why I found out because a lot
of my employees were like complaining to
you about stealing their children yeah
did you guys hear about the 69 Hour Work
Week in South Korea 69 69 420.
why'd you say that because it's it goes
together they don't go together that's
true I don't think so for four o'clock
do they get off at four o'clock in 20
minutes hey dude we're a mature show
over here okay we're trying to like
Elevate we're trying to elevate okay how
many that's old JFK JFK that's it yes
that's a whole JFK that's eight minutes
ago JK yeah okay we're not doing that
[__] anymore watch it okay yeah we moved
on sorry Steve what were you saying so
the government
um intended to raise the maximum weekly
working time to 69 hours and I'm not
kidding about that they actually picked
69 hours which I guess is
that like a good luck number in in Asian
countries or something it should be
why do they work six days a week or five
the current cap is 50 52 hours how many
days seven days a week or six that's ten
hours that's a little over 10 hours so
but then if it's 69 divided by that's
13.8 hours oh fact five if you work five
days they include a lunch break
oh because then they're just working
normal hours 12 hour a day that's almost
14. I mean like that's 13 points true I
mean I'm talking you know Asian
standards yeah I wonder that they clock
out the government announced that
they're intending to raise the minimum
weekly working time to 69 hours
and then protests all of a sudden sprang
out from the country's Millennials in
Generation Z which prompted the
president uh to call them lazy
um to order government agencies to
reconsider the measure and communicate
better with the public especially with
generations and Millennials did the
protests last longer than the work day
would have yeah
I'm surprised they just didn't call the
aunties my point exactly whatever ladle
my mom would have been like good
so yeah they're saying that the core of
their labor market policy is to try to
protect the rights and interests of
underprivileged workers
um
isn't it funny though that we're trying
to reduce like uh we're trying to do
like a four day work week or something
yeah I saw that Congress Congress yeah
and then they're doing the opposite way
because they're trying to crush us
they're trying to actually win that for
everyone they hire no they're trying
well he's trying to say we're trying to
protect the rights and interests of
underprivileged workers right
um but
so he's saying all this while he's being
super pro business and saying like we're
going to raise the fight we're trying to
protect you by giving you more hours
you're gonna get paid more it's just
your life expectancy is going to drop in
a country where like uh they're having a
population crisis is an answer to that
to make people work more does that help
that's probably what it is because then
instead of finding more people to fill
the hours you can use the same people
just filling those days and make them
meet at work yeah maybe they're just
trying to maybe that extra hour of work
is just socialized yeah it depends so
like a big mixer everybody has a work
boyfriend a work girlfriend or a
boyfriend here's my workbook what about
part-time we are I don't think it says
can there's no part time wait did you
say part-time or apartheid apartheid
you're welcome to come host it if you
want yeah come host okay I hosted last
week 69 hour part-time part-time
employee we're looking for a 69 hour
part-time
skills require 69ing and the liquid 420
is
so you got those two things you're in
make sure you're free at 4 20 every day
so there are there are other countries
right like Britain where they
um are trialing four-day work weeks and
dozens of companies gave that a shot and
said that it resulted in similar or
better productivity and increased staff
well-being interesting well yeah no [__]
the guy right in that report's working
less too
that makes no sense you saw that coming
I don't know it's it's funny because I
I'll see like these uh memes about how
like Oh I'm a business owner and I
changed working from my nine to five to
now a five to nine
so they're vampire now so basically they
work yeah you work you end up working
more I will say this working nights I
mean as an actor it's completely
different but it sucks when you work
nights because your life is just [__]
flipped upside I used to work graveyard
in a in a in a restaurant so hard man
because you make way [__] more when
you take the graveyard shift of like
like from like say like let's say from
six to like four a.m right if you work
where there's alcohol all that because
you make the most in tips
if your restaurant doesn't share tip and
you just get to keep whatever they pay
you but then you don't see the Sun and
then you get sick and all that stuff but
yeah shouldn't they have to share tips
everywhere
don't you agree with that Joe no
[__] no if I get if I get tipped because
I did some extra favors you aren't
taking any of that I had to suck dick
for it yeah you know what's kind of
weird um professionally I was there
uncomfortable when you go to a
restaurant and then uh the server
straight up tells you before you tip
he's like hey the tips don't it won't go
to me so they do that yeah I heard that
recently I went to an Indian restaurant
hey give me cash at an Indian restaurant
the guy was like Hey if you had the tip
with your card I'll never get it he's
like it'll just go to the all the
difference nah dude what Indian
restaurant let's go right now let's
settle this I'm gonna go in I'm gonna
say same thing and be like bring out
your [__] mom
okay let me tell you yeah you know what
you know why you didn't get that tip
because your mom's in the back that's
why a lot of businesses just like fine
he's right he's not gonna get that tip
his mom's gonna take it off yeah a lot
of businesses steal tip yeah a lot of
them yeah that's why I found out because
a lot of my employees were like uh
they're like complaining to you about
stealing their children yeah
people tip okay they're like wait like
wait you gotta stop stealing our tips
and I'm like but I'm hungry I need lunch
now all the snacks you brought us today
basically what I found out is that when
at their other jobs or whatever if cash
is short like they can't buy [__]
ingredients they just win it to the tip
jar and started buying stuff and they're
like wait so we get to keep our tips
they were so happy that they got breaks
they got tip money they got like I was
like this shit's just legal stuff that
they're supposed to do isn't it amazing
when you treat people with the bare
minimum it's crazy when we like you a
little bit everyone does it illegally so
then when you just follow the rules bare
minimum they're hella grateful right
because but that blows my mind because
in California
if you did that you'd be so [__]
screwed from all the lawsuits yeah dude
I remember just showing up at my old job
like my high-rise job and them thinking
I'm some kind of All-Star because I
showed up and like I would just do my
job at time on time yeah yeah like I
would just show up do my students that's
true though what was everyone's first
job you guys all grew up here right yeah
yeah what was like your first real job
as an adult I suppose I was an adult
like out of school like not like past
high school or college I was the manager
of Management Services for a company in
downtown L.A where we we ran all the
printers in defense contractors not
kidding that's Lockheed Martin I would
have techs that went to those buildings
oh it's a good job that's a really good
thing sounds good it sounds sick it was
an office admin job okay but but that
was my title but then I got paid [__]
for it but it was cool that I was like
sending people into these government
buildings they all had to have
classified yeah like what do they call
it clear credentials right yeah that was
a cartoon technician at Target
shopping cart technician but that that
was the top that you're like fixing
that's all like yeah gave you some
dignity baby cart technician you got the
little thing with the remote thing that
that you can push the cart with it oh
that's pretty tight oh that is kind of
tight I don't see people using that
anymore these days they're all doing an
old school by hand manual yeah
mine was a in 2001 I was the cell phone
dude at the kiosk at the mall sick yeah
you gotta like some covers yeah but by
the no not conversely actual phones say
you want MetroPCS were you that guy for
your T-Mobile it was it was T-Mobile
prior to
um well it was it was actually Verizon
prior to it it used to be called
something else before it blew up Bell
Atlantic it's called mobile Atlantic oh
yeah but then by that time it was
illegal to to Shark People you could go
hey you got a phone like you couldn't
yell oh really it was illegal to speak
in public because they made it the
public I don't know if you guys remember
but in the late 90s that got so
obnoxious it was so [__] people
stopped going to the mall because they
didn't want to be toxicity
so they're like Ryan it's your fault
stop yelling at customer every initiate
conversation someone had to initiate
with you they had to go like hey what's
is that when you learned how to spin on
your head yeah you're like if I learned
a spin on my head they'll just come up
dude you're like how to become a better
salesman I'll become an incredible
breakdown but it was all commissioned
back then so you could I went two
straight weeks sometimes making zero
dollars oh no
nothing it was all commission so what'd
you do if you can't talk to people just
stand there you can't sit that's so
against your personality literally just
stand there yeah I just made paper
airplanes all day and threw them in the
winter did you make faces blinded 25
children in 1999
[Music]